thank you for having me
here so my name is Zach I'm a machine
learning engineer at atrium atrium is a
legal company it's a law firm based in
San Francisco and also happens to employ
a lot of engineers which I'm one you
might be wondering why does a walk
company need to have all these engineers
and the answer is that atriums goal as
shown in this Washington Post article is
to replace lawyers with robots okay I'm
just kidding that's not actually the
goal that's like the height version of
the goal the real goal of atrium and the
engineering team at atrium is to save
time for workers and paralegals make
them more efficient at their jobs I'll
finish you they do their jobs better by
automating some of the boring rote stuff
that they have to do every single day so
the area that in particular that we're
working on right now is intake what
intake is is let's say you're a client
of atriums right so you signed up with
us
you're a promising young startup and
maybe you're switching from your old law
firm that you don't like very much
and you have a whole big zip file of
legal documents which could be anything
it could be your employee contracts it
could be your board consents your stock
purchase agreements it could be your old
bank receipts anything you got a
thousand of these documents you send
them all to atrium and we have our
paralegals go through every single
document when I say we do I mean we used
to before the ml team did its thing and
this is what happens at big law firms
now is that a you get those chips to the
paralegals they have all these documents
they have to go through each and every
document and figure out okay what type
of contract is this and who's the
investor how much did they invest what's
the date that the contract was executed
all this stuff they have to open each
document individually scroll through try
and find where the information is in the
document copy it paste it into an Excel
spreadsheet and it's pretty
time-consuming an adult also doesn't
really utilize any of their legal skills
that they went to school to develop and
overall it takes them about two minutes
per document they go through about
in an hour so what the ml team is doing
at atrium is we're automating some of
this stuff and we're having an algorithm
go through and look at the documents and
make guesses about which parts of the
document represent the investor name
which part represent the the discount
rate that the investment is at all of
that kind of stuff now these are not
zero touch models what I mean by zero
touch model is a model of it is always
right hundred percent of the time that's
not really how machine learning works
right there's always some kind of error
rate and we can't really afford that in
the legal world we have to be very
accurate so instead what the model does
is it'll make guesses you input a
document and it'll say okay we think
that this is the interest rate we think
that this is the investor and we passed
that along to the paralegal so the
parallel you can either quickly either
accept the suggestion or reject the
suggestion you can draw an analogy here
to the P versus NP problem where it's a
lot easier this for my computational
complexity people out there it's a lot
easier to verify a solution than it is
to find the solution yourself like if
someone gave you a huge prime number
you'd be hard-pressed to find what the
factors are it's super hard to do but if
somebody told you I think the prime
numbers are this and this it would be
pretty simple for you to multiply those
together and see if they weren't back
the prime numbers that multiply to make
the number so we make these guesses and
the paralegals check whether the guesses
are right or not and if it's right then
they can just quickly accept it saves
them a whole bunch of time and as a team
we're down to we can actually do 150
documents in an hour now which is a big
increase from the 30 that we're doing
prior to the introduction of these
techniques so how does the algorithm do
all this cool stuff the model that we
use is called a conditional random field
or CRF for short and it's kind of
similar to a hidden Markov model if you
put are those except that it's
discriminative instead of generative and
it makes fewer independence assumptions
if you don't know what hidden Markov
model means you don't know what
generative discriminative means please
do not worry that's what this talk is
gonna be all about and one more thing
before I start getting into math which
is that if you have any questions about
something I'm saying then please raise
your hand
during the talk because there's probably
lot of other people out there that have
your exact same question all right so
before we get into the actual legal
document aspect of it we're going to
take a detour to the world of the 2000s
movie disturbia starring Shia LaBeouf I
hope I pronounced that right and in this
movie he's plays the role of an XD
teenager who is confined by injury to
his house and he can't actually go
outside all he can do is look out the
window and see whether see what his
neighbors are up to basically so we're
gonna pretend that we collectively in
this room are Shia LaBeouf and we're
gonna try and predict what the weather
is outside we're gonna try and predict
whether it's rainy or sunny but we can't
actually see the weather because we're
house bound all we can see is whether
our neighbor is carrying an umbrella or
is not carrying an umbrella when they
leave the house so to simplify things
we're going to assume that there's two
states that the weather can be in either
it's sunny in a certain day or its rainy
during that day and we're gonna assume
that it doesn't change during the course
of a day in any given day it's either
sunny or it's rainy and what this means
is that there's four different
transition probabilities between the
states it can either go from sunny to
sunny or sunny to rainy with some
probability it can go from rainy to
rainy or rain into sunny and to make the
math a little bit simpler we're gonna
assume that the weather always stays the
same
with probability 3/4 and always changes
with probability 1/4 so 3/4 of the time
if it was sunny today I'll be sunny
tomorrow
1/4 of the time it's gonna flip now
given this information about the
transition probabilities between the
states what we're going to try to do now
is we're going to try and calculate the
probability of a specific sequence of
three different states across three
different days given what the weather
was on the starting date so we're going
to assume that it was sunny on day 0 now
let's say we don't look at days two and
three on this board but we're only
looking
day one given that it's sunny on day
zero anyone have any guesses about what
the weather is going to be like on day
one sorry what are the odds that will be
sunny nice 75% cool so that was easy now
it's going to get a little trickier
given that it was sunny on day zero and
day one now we want to look at de to
bring that into the equation so what are
the odds that it's sunny on day one and
sunny on day two given that it was sunny
on day zero I heard 75 times 75 which is
exactly right what we're going to do is
multiply the 0.75 by the 0.75 end up
with 56% now the reason that it's okay
to do this is the conditional
independence of day two and day zero
given our knowledge of what the weather
was like on day one so I'm not saying
that day zero and day two the weather on
those two days is independent because
it's not independent if you know that
it's sunny on day zero that tells you
something about what the probability is
likely to be on day one if it's sunny on
day zero it's probably gonna be Sunday
on day one if it's sunny on day one it's
probably also going to be sunny on day
two so knowing what the weather is like
on day zero does actually give you some
information about what the weather is
going to be like on day two
but given the knowledge of what the
weather was like on Monday now the
weather on day zero is independent of
the weather on day two and that's
because all the information about the
sunniness
or lack thereof on Sunday sort of got
encapsulated into what the weather was
like on Monday we only cared about what
the weather was like on Sunday insofar
as it told us that it was more likely to
be sunny on Monday which then told us
that it was wrong I could it be Sunday
on Tuesday but once we sort of interrupt
that chain by telling by it by being
given information about what it was like
on Monday now the probability of sunny
Tuesday and sunny Sunday are actually
independent all right
so now that we know that we can do that
how do we get then the combined
probability of all of these three
different states from sunny to rainy
what are we going to do just shout it
out
multiply by 0.25 and we end up with a
14% probability of having this exact
sequence of states and these sequence of
states are what we care about getting
the probability of these are later the
analogy is going to be that these hidden
weather states are going to be like the
hidden states that are determining
whether something is investor name or
not now we're going to bring the
observations into it the disturbia part
of it and here are the two observations
that we could make about the weather our
sorry about the umbrella status of our
of our neighbor either they have an
umbrella or they don't have an umbrella
those are the two observations that we
could see and these observations the
probability of our neighbor either
having an umbrella or not having an
umbrella is determined by the weather so
we're gonna assume that when it's sunny
our neighbor being a reasonable person
usually does not have an umbrella
although some of the time they do maybe
it's just a fashion statement and when
its rainy we're gonna assume that they
bring an umbrella 50% of the time and
don't bring one 50% of the time so these
are the probabilities of seeing these
observations given the underlying States
which by the way the fact that the
states are hidden and that we don't see
them that's where the hidden in hidden
Markov model comes from so these are the
probabilities of the observations given
the states what we want to use these to
find is the probability of the
underlying states given the observations
since that were is where we're at we
don't see what state the the world is in
we just see these observations and we
want to infer what the probabilities of
the states are given these observations
that we made
so to help us do this I drew out this
nice schematic diagram where I labeled
ten sample days we took ten sample days
where it was sunny and we took ten
sample days where it was rainy I should
keep this on for my purposes and I put
an umbrella next to there if we saw an
umbrella that day and I put no umbrella
we didn't see an umbrella so because of
these ten ninety figures you can see
that there is one day where it was sunny
and there was a person had an umbrella
and there was nine days where was sunny
where they didn't have an umbrella and
on the 10 days where was rainy they had
an umbrella five out of those ten days
and those are like what we would expect
to see on average given these
probabilities so using these numbers
finding the probabilities of the states
given the observations is now as simple
as just counting if we look at the total
number of days where there's an umbrella
in this picture can you guys see this by
the way yeah cool you can see that
there's one day where there was umbrella
and Sun and five days where there was
umbrella and rain which means that given
that we see an umbrella the odds that it
were sunny is going to be one out of six
we can do the exact same thing to get
the probability that it's raining or
sunny given that the president doesn't
have an umbrella and we see that there
is 14 total of these cases where the
person did not have an umbrella on a
certain day 9 to them it was sunny so
the odds that it was the underlying
state is sunny given the observation of
no umbrella is not out of 14 what's
interesting about this is that when it's
raining they have an umbrella 50 percent
of the time so you might think that just
because they have an umbrella or not
that doesn't give us any information
because when it's raining they could
they're equally likely to have an
umbrella or not have an umbrella but the
key is that when it's sunny they're very
likely to not have an umbrella so them
not having an umbrella serves as
evidence that it is sunny outside
now this is not a causal relationship
it's not like when our neighbor carries
around an umbrella that actually makes
it more likely to rain that's not what's
going on some people think it is like
that's basically what superstition is is
reversing the order of these effects
yeah yeah yeah or if you don't bring an
umbrella 'then like for sure it's gonna
rain that day all right because the data
you forgot it so yeah that's no there's
no causality going on here it's not like
what we see about this umbrella is
determining whether it rains or not but
despite that there's still this this
probabilistic link between the two that
allows us to to make guesses about what
the weather is we've kept it pretty
simple so far and we've kept it to just
one observation umbrella or no umbrella
but that's by no means necessary and we
can actually look at multiple different
observations like we might notice that
our neighbor is wearing rain boots or
sneakers that could give us some
observation about some information about
the weather and we might notice that
they have a skeleton that we feel it in
our bones wait I remember a little bit
auto order on these slides hold on here
we go
uh-huh yeah so if you feel it in your
bones that's gonna rain that could be
another example of an observation that
is telling you some information about
the the weather that you can then
combine with your other observations to
get a combined probability so skipping
back a little bit before we were just
looking at one day at a time
given some observation on one day what
are the odds on that specific day that
it was rainy or sunny where it gets a
little more interesting is when we have
a sequence of two days so here's two
observations that we made on Monday we
worked out our window and we saw that
our neighbor had an umbrella and on
Tuesday we looked up we saw they didn't
have an umbrella and now what we want to
figure out is what is the most likely
underlying sequence of states that gave
rise to these two observations
there's four possible sequences right it
could have been rainy than rainy could
have been rain even sunny could have
been sunny than Sunday could have been
sunny than rainy there's four different
possibilities for what the states could
have been we want to figure out what the
most likely sequence of states was what
you say I love that you said that
because if we're looking at the days
individually the most likely choice on
on the day where they had an umbrella we
just calculated this when we found it on
the days where the person has an
umbrella there's a five six chance that
it's raining so if we're just looking at
Monday in isolation we think that he
probably had an umbrella or we think
there was probably rainy on on Monday
and we think it was probably sunny on
Tuesday because most of the time when
there's no umbrella it was sunny and
that's a great first intuition to have
but it does ignore one very important
feature of this model that we've set up
exactly it's not likely to transition
between these states we have this prior
knowledge that the weather is like
usually staying the same and because of
this we're predisposed to believe in
underlying sequences of states that
don't have a lot of transitions between
different weather types so I'm not going
to go through the exact math and getting
these numbers but I will footnote it by
saying that if you want to know exactly
how these numbers get calculated you
should Google forward backward algorithm
or Viterbi algorithm you can find some
cool animations online but for now you
can just take my word for it that it's
more likely that the states when rain
even rainy rather than going from rainy
to study and the reason for that is we
just don't really believe that it's that
likely to change over
so we're biasing ourselves towards
explanations that don't involve a lot of
change over us
cool any questions up to now
okay in that case we will talk about how
these numbers got arrived at in this
example I was sort of the omniscient
narrator and I told you all what the
chances were of these transitions
between states and I told you all about
what the probabilities of the
observations were given the underlying
states in the real world we don't have
this this this voice telling us what all
the probabilities are and this is where
the labeled data comes into the model so
we have a bunch of paralegals on staff
that have annotated a bunch of documents
in the past and they've said we're all
the in in weather world it's like we had
a meteorological history of the area and
we took notes historically of how often
the weather was to transition between
these states and we've kept alike
careful notes and we've written down
like what exactly what's going on with
the umbrella on each day and we used
that to find out what these these
question mark percentages were and you
know no model is is complete without
data so this is where the data enters
this model and being done with weather
we're going to move back to the English
language and the analogy that we're
going to make here is that the weather
this underlying state of the weather
which determined these observations that
we saw which caused the person to have
an umbrella or not the weather is going
to be like what part of speech a
sentence is in at any given time and
then the observations the umbrella part
is going to be like what word gets
emitted so you can think of a sentence
as moving from part of speech to part of
speech you know preposition or PRP
actually don't know what PRP stands for
but PRP to VBP to a verb to a determiner
at center etc the sentence is moving
from part of speech to part of speech
and what part of speech is sentences in
determines it's probability of emitting
a certain word so like let's say let's
take the word dog for example like the
fourth word in this sentence
it's possible that the word dog could be
emitted by a verb state it's possible
that if the sentence is a verb right now
that we're going to see the word dog
because dog can be used as a verb so the
probability of dog given verb is non
zero but it's not as high as the
probability of dog given noun because
dog is more commonly used as a noun
than it is as a verb but it's both are
dramatically higher than the odds of
seeing the word dog given that we're at
a preposition state because you I don't
even think the word dog can be a
preposition so what this means is that
in the same way as we are trying to
predict the most likely series of states
given the observations before given the
weather observations given these word
observations we're trying to predict the
underlying sequence of parts of speech
that gave rise to these observations and
just as we had multiple observations
before you know the umbrella and the
boots here we're not just limited to
looking at the exact word that came out
but we can also look at these other
aspects of the word so for instance we
can look at what are the first three
letters of the word or what are the last
three letters of the word or what is the
previous word or what's the next word
these are all different features that we
can use features means the same thing as
observations in this case I'm using them
synonymously and you can add your own
features to this list like I'm sure you
guys could think of different features
of a word we have a bunch of them and
that's some of the main things that we
work on is just thinking about new
features that we could add to this model
that are going to make it more accurate
so here is an example of a legal
document this is just one paragraph of a
legal document it's not an entire legal
document but you can see it has a bunch
of words in it and we're going to try
and figure out what the odds are what
the most likely series of states are
that gave rise to the
words but we're not going to use all the
different parts of speech because we
don't actually care at a walk company
whether people are using verbs or nouns
rather we're gonna label most of the
words in the sentence as Oh which means
that we don't care about them at all
they're just irrelevant to us and then a
select few of the words are going to be
lucky enough to get their own label in
this case we're gonna try and label
who's the investor and how much did they
invest and if the model did a good job
then what it outputs is gonna look like
this almost every word in the document
is going to have a label of oh we don't
care about it but the two words that are
part of the investor name are going to
get their own label so these things on
the right are like the states these
labels that like the states and then the
words these are like the observations
and this is an ideal world where the
model worked as an expected common error
that we see in this amount is that it
might miss the the dollar sign or it
might miss a period so it can actually
get part of the answer right but part of
the answer wrong and in those cases when
it's partially right or partially wrong
it's still useful to the paralegals
because it's still telling them where
the document to look and that's why we
are using this as a combined human and
machine teamwork thing rather than just
letting the algorithm and do it all on
its own because it's not gonna be
perfect alright we'll talk about some
strengths of the CRF model so some
strengths are that you can choose
whatever features you want to choose you
can really dream big with this in fact
you can use like an entire other model
just as input to this model an example
of this would be that we actually have a
part of speech tagger we use Spacey's
part of speech tagger and we run it over
the entire legal document and it gives
us part of speech labels at each word in
the sentence those words are then used
as sorry those labels from the part of
speech tagger are then used as features
or observations for the CRF that's
making the predictions some other
features that we use
we use whether the word is a number or
not that's a really good one for knowing
whether it's interest rate or not we
have a list of months and if the word is
on that list of months that's a good
feature for the model to know about we
also downloaded a list of the most
common baby names in the US and the most
common baby names in the world and
that's a good feature to use when we're
trying to predict whether something is
an investor name or not now keep in mind
that we're not in putting the weights of
these features we're not telling the
model how much to care about whether a
given word is an investor name or not
we're just telling it that it's
something that it should pay attention
to in shia labeouf world these analogy
to this would be like a telescope like a
tool that we can use that's helping us
make these observations but it's not
actually telling us what the answer is
it's just giving us some some input so
another strength of the CRF model is
that it's relatively simple and doesn't
have that many parameters when you
compare it to something like
bidirectional lsdm those types of models
are more appropriate when you have tons
of data but atrium is pretty young
company I joined in May was 50 people
now we're at like 130 people we still
have about 1,000 documents per document
type which means that using these
smaller models is a little bit more
appropriate than using a big model
that's gonna have a higher risk of
overfitting which as we all know is one
of the cardinal sins of machine learning
so witnesses of the CRF model are that
you have to hard-code your features if
you use a fancy new shiny model it's
gonna pick out all those features for
you and it'll do that sort of discovery
work and it has pluses and minuses it
can make it less interpretable but it
can also make it less work to do and
more general and another possible
weakness of the CRF model is this
assumption that the only thing that
matters in these state transition
probabilities is the states immediately
before and after so that whole thing
about you know if it's Sunday if it's if
it's Tuesday we don't care about what
the weather was like
Sunday we only care about what it was
like on Monday that's not really true
and whether and it's also not really
true in English it actually does matter
what the weather was like two days ago
but just to make the model more
computationally tractable and easier to
execute we're ignoring that fact and
moving on so I'm about to turn it over
to questions before I do quick plug for
my colleague Jordan bramble who's going
to give in awesome talk in about half an
hour about some of the other cool work
that we do at atrium including finding
signatures and finding the absence of
signatures in legal documents and also
just to let you guys know we are hiring
so if you go to atrium Co /pi data you
can see a list of all our super cool
open positions all right that's it
question this yeah with word vectors
yeah we actually did at the time that we
experimented with word vectors we built
a bi-directional LS TM that used word
vectors at that time we had a lot less
data we had only about 300 documents per
document type something I didn't say in
this talk cuz want to keep it quick is
that we actually build different models
for each document type weather world
this would be like people are more or
less likely to carry umbrellas depending
on what state you're living in or what
they like you know where you are what
your region is so we have different
models for each document type at the
time when we tried the the word vectors
in the bidirectional LS TM we only had
about 300 documents per document type
now we're up to about a thousand so
we're sort of getting to the point where
we want to explore using deep warning
again which is pretty exciting right so
yeah we can use the we didn't calculate
the word vectors out ourselves
we took a list of word vectors that we
downloaded from the internet and then
use those instead of the words and then
ran it through a bio SDM put a CF on top
which is sort of a standard thing that
you do
yes actually we did because you might
think that there's like these templates
for legal documents right like maybe
everyone who used prior law firm X they
all all of their legal documents look
the same and everyone whose prior law
firm Y all their documents look the same
and that if you can classify them like
that then that'll give you a lot it
input but what we found is that the the
clusters that we tried to make weren't
really that distinct from each other and
it didn't really work that well I think
we just did TF it was actually another
engineer on the team but I believe we
just used tf-idf and pretty standard
stuff yeah all I should repeat these
questions out loud the question was are
these PDFs that we're using yes so great
question
they are PDFs sometimes they're dot Docs
but whatever they are we send them all
up to Google cloud OCR which then
returns back a series of text and in
fact along with the exact text the
document google OCR is also returning a
bounding box around each word and one of
the features that we use is the location
of that bounding box on the page for
instance if you're high up on the page
it's more likely that you're an investor
named because people usually put the
name of the investor at the top and also
what page you're on in the document can
affect how likely something is to be a
different thing that we care about yeah
yes
great question so we do the question was
have we tried using regular expressions
we found that that works pretty well for
some document types in particular
there's one called a safe which is the
standard investment vehicle that's used
in San Francisco with Y Combinator which
is one of the biggest incubators and we
found that regular expressions work
pretty darn well on a safe and we use
those for a while but just recently the
performance of this model exceeded the
performance of the regular expressions
so we've now switched over to using that
yeah yeah so we're all employed by the
legal firm and all the documents are
strictly confidential not seen by anyone
outside the company so if you're ok with
a wire seeing your documents and you're
okay with a paralegal seeing your
documents then you're ok with an
engineer who works at the company also
seen your documents so atrium is is no
it's a great question so the question
was are a lot different law firms hiring
us to go through their documents
so we're exclusively doing this on the
data of our own clients because atrium
is has this sort of unique profile where
it's half a wall company half a legal
company the law firm as its clients it
has you know different startups and us
as the tech half of the company it's
almost like our clients are no lawyers
so we're building products to serve them
right and we're not sharing anything in
companies B's documents with company a
it's all just internal do you want to
say that louder okay yeah
awesome question so the question was how
do we segregate the documents into these
different document types so that we know
which model to use and we actually have
a separate model that does that and it
trained on different documents that have
been labeled by paralegals and that
model is super accurate that model is
really almost at the point of being
zero-touch it's about ninety three
percent of the time our first guess is
right about ninety nine percent of the
time the correct document type is in our
top list of five so yes we have one
model we have this hierarchical system
of models the first model tells you
which document type it is and the second
model does all the Seraph stuff that we
just talked about to classify yet
straight-up tf-idf with the words
they're in the document so basically
like if if we see that all this stock
purchase agreements have the word stock
and the word purchase and then we see
another document that has those words
there we go it's probably the same one
as the other document that had all these
words in it yeah
for pre-processing that the text data to
run these CRFs we don't do any
pre-processing at all and that's kind of
might be a surprise to some of you who
are if you've worked in NLP you know
that pre-processing is usually like a
very important first step the reason
that we don't is that the stop words can
actually be extremely important and even
the specific differences between a stem
version and an unstable world could have
a lot of implications
it's also why word vectors aren't as
effective as you might think because
just cuz two words like vaguely mean the
same thing in the English language and
are like similar to each other and use a
similar context that doesn't really mean
that there could still be a world of
difference in their usage in a legal
context yeah the model would would
probably still work if you trained it on
Spanish or French documents if you had
enough of them but I think so far all of
our clients legal data has been in
English so we haven't had to deal with
that issue yet yeah how many document
types we have it depends how like
low-level you want to go into the genus
yeah right so we have right now we have
six document types that we have models
for that cover of most of our documents
but as we get more and more examples
we're gonna keep training more and more
document types yeah
the question was if there's if we can
classify the documents by like the the
the nature of the client right well most
of our clients are Bay Area startups in
San Francisco
that's like atriums official like
mission is to be like the dominant legal
startup for Bay Area our bhalil company
for a berry startup so right now we
don't have these regional differences
going on but once we expand into the
furthest reaches of the world then maybe
we'll look into that
yeah yes great question is there any
effort to standardize legal documents
for like machine interpretation
absolutely and the SAF which I talked
about is like one of the first steps
towards that but if you achieve market
dominance as a legal firm then you get a
lot of ability to set the the parameters
and we would like to do that to to make
all this a lot easier
yeah so a lot of our clients are coming
to us from other companies and for those
clients we don't really have a lot of
control over what their legal setup is
before since it's just whatever they
were doing with our past law firm but
for newer clients we try to get them
into a more standardized track yeah
you're saying do we put the information
in tables once we extract it mmm yes
there is
sometimes information in tables and
documents and no we don't have an
official approach for dealing with that
but it's a really good idea and
something that we should look into yeah
yeah so right now we're at about
two-thirds accuracy right so if the
model the model 2/3 of the time it'll
correctly pull out the investor name or
pull out the date from the document if
we get that to literal 100% then the
paralegals can all focus on more
interesting things than intake and then
the time goes to zero zero minutes per
document so we just want to push that as
close as possible another thing that we
want to do is get better balance on how
confident we are about a certain
prediction so even if we're not right
100% of the time if we can be right a
hundred percent of the time on 50% of
the documents but we know which percent
of the documents those are and for those
documents we can skip the human in the
loop part and we can just go straight to
the automation and for the rest of them
we can continue to do our current thing
of having a human who checks it over
yeah
yes yes so when the humans you know to
tell the model oh you were right or oh
you were wrong that all gets recorded in
a database and actually that's what I'm
gonna be working on as soon as this
conference is over is looping that back
into the model so that it has more data
to work with yep yeah so like what kind
of errors does the model make a lot of
errors that the model make makes comes
from come from the the OCR so sometimes
the OCR will tokenize the word in a
weird way like it'll have the period
like if it's you know twenty thousand
point zero zero dollars sometimes it'll
have twenty thousand point zero zero all
is one word
sometimes I'll have it as 20 comma zero
zero zero period zero zero and in cases
like that it's a lot more likely that
the model will make a mistake and also
sometimes the OCR is just wrong like it
just won't get the right letters OCR is
not perfect so that's like an active
area that we're looking into is
improving the quality o CR maybe by like
using a few different OCR things or
jittering the image slightly and then
combining the results of OCR on the
original image and all these jittered
images so that's one area and aside from
that it seems to have the biggest
trouble with people who have like names
that the model hasn't seen before
yeah
that's interesting so you could
basically say like for every client
ignore the the name of that client if it
appears in the document or never
returned the name of a client as the
counterparty and one of those clients
documents I got to give these talks more
often because you are coming up with
some great ideas that we need to
implement yeah it's not open source our
data is definitely not open source it's
like as closed as a source can be so but
the way we use something called pi CRF
suite and that is open source the only
modification that we made to it is we
basically tweaked it so that it's biased
against returning these O's and it's
biased for just like freaking out and
thinking that everything is an investor
name and the reason that we did it that
way is that we care a lot more about our
recall than our precision so if the
models like oh there's like six
different counterparties like that's a
counterparty and that's a counterparty
they're all counterparties because of
this like PNP thing it's a lot easier
for the the paralegal to be like well
these five are all trash but then this
one is really good and that's better
than if it doesn't give any guesses and
then the paralegal has to just use the
fail case of like looking it up
themselves it's like a cache miss so we
tweaked it a little bit to bias it
against returning like whatever the most
common libel is but aside from that it's
it's pretty standard Parsi ref sweet
stuff yeah could you repeat that
higher-order CRFs
yeah yeah yeah we have so we have like
journal club every week and we read
papers and talk about implementing them
and the most recent one we read was on
these skip chain CRFs which don't have
the assumption that uh that these
different states from a long time ago
don't influence them and that's another
area that we'd like to look into
we haven't actually tried them yet all
right cool
[Applause]